people need religion because of various
universal experiences that we all have
to face I'm thinking of course most
obviously of mortality but you can think
of other areas where humans have to face
very intense kinds of moments so the
moment of birth all of the questions
around suffering an illness how people
heal these are all universal encounters
that humans have and that require
something more something meaningful and
something that can be transformative to
people's lives and I don't think we can
really reduce why people are religious
to any one particular thing but it
certainly relates to our experience as
embodied human beings well in the world
we live today religion cannot be
contained within the walls of the church
or the temple or the mosque and in fact
religion and i would say religious
sensibilities really spill out from
those institutional settings and
infiltrate and penetrate just about it
really every area of social life
everything from economics to
entertainment obviously politics there
is a way in which we can't
compartmentalize religion as a separate
sphere but in fact it really has become
an important force in terms of people's
motivations in terms of peoples
investments in terms of people's
commitments and all of those cut across
the different areas of life that we find
ourselves everyday religion really can
be found in a lot of different to
unexpected places so I've written about
religion and the religious experience of
film going whether you can talk about
the Star Wars saga as
being a new generator of mythic ideas
and somehow tapping in to some of our
deepest fears and most profound hopes of
good battling evil and people having the
possibility to transform identities I
mean now film is a carrier of different
kinds of religious messages that I think
are just as powerful for people in their
everyday lives as the usual suspects of
the Quran or the Bible and things of
that nature people are very concerned
and preoccupied with longevity and
especially in the society we live in
today when we have certain medical
technologies that can really prolong
life in ways that we never imagined in
people's life spans have grown
dramatically you know especially in the
last few decades and all of that really
is speaks to great advances and I think
it also speaks to an underlying fear of
death as well we want to live as long as
we can we certainly don't want to face
our end for as long as we can put it off
but part of that obsession with
longevity and long life I think also has
to do with our obsessions with youth and
our desire not just to age well but to
overcome age and to maintain a youthful
spirit I mean these are certainly
cultural messages that we receive every
day and that makes growing old in our
society actually quite difficult
compared with other cultures
unfortunately religion can be both a
inspiration for great works and all
kinds of altruistic activities but on
the other hand it can also lead to the
most aggressive and violent and
destructive actions imaginable
throughout history you can find all
kinds of evidence of this fundamentalism
may not be the appropriate word but you
can certainly say most religious
traditions have extremists that can
really take the teachings of the
religions and transform them into
reasons to kill and reasons to harm
reasons to cause suffering and I don't
think any of the religious traditions
are immune from from that side of
religion the Bush administration really
is gets failing grades in how they've
taken care of religion and the kind of
role that it's played in the bush
administration I think the kind of
forceful explicit putting forth of
religious beliefs as an important factor
in the running of government has has
really been a travesty considering the
First Amendment and our our country's
history and I think I deals around the
relationship between religion and
government well I just published a new
book it's called sacred matters
celebrity worship sexual ecstasy 'he's
the living dead and other signs of
religious life in the united states it's
published by the new press and it really
is trying to argue that there's more to
religious life to whether or not you
believe in God there's more to religious
life than how you self-identify as an
evangelical or a Catholic or a Jew and
that there are certain areas of social
life that really become sacred to people
and they become great sources of meaning
and identity and the potential for
transformation and community so I'm
trying to look at these different sacred
sources by looking across the spectrum
certain areas of social life some of the
some of the chapters
look at celebrity some look at sports
one looks at sexuality one looks at
violence one looks at death so all of
these areas I think become very
significant for how Americans understand
and participate in religious cultures
that are just as meaningful as their
activities in the church or temple and
indeed religious cultures that don't
always contradict or take the place of
those religious identities but instead
what I'm trying to argue is that people
have multiple religious identities not
just singular monolithic identities and
that's what I'm trying to get at in this
book part of what the book is arguing is
that you can find religious commitments
and investments and experiences and what
might be unusual places so in terms of
celebrity you can certainly look at
Oprah as a religious phenomenon that is
not about Christianity only or Judaism
only more Hinduism only it's about a
different kind of religious nexus and
culture that really surrounds this
particular icon but that's only only
really one example there throughout US
history you can look at this at the
Hollywood sort of celebrity factory and
find other icons who become figures that
are worshiped I mean you can talk about
someone like Elvis Presley is another
one who really seems to arouse certain
kinds of religious passions and
activities whether it's listening to the
music and you know remembering a
particular time in your life or going to
visit Graceland and finding that to be
in a meaningful experience of pilgrimage
so celebrity that would be a couple of
examples within celebrity in terms of
sexuality there is a whole range of
literature around
sacred sex that really talks about the
experience of experiences of sex as a
pathway to certain kinds of spiritual
experiences I talked in my book about
actually someone who writes about SNM
within the lesbian and gay community and
really in very explicit language talks
about that ritual and sexuality as it
surrounds certain kinds of acts between
people as really potentially not for
everybody not all the time but
potentially leading to experiences that
require religious language and and so
that's what I'm trying to get at is you
know what kinds of vocabularies do we
use to describe experiences that rely on
certain kinds of religious images or
models or modes of thinking and
certainly you can find that in again a
range of different human areas